DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
In this problem, I'd like you to
compute the area of a triangle.
This triangle sits
in space and it
has its three vertices labeled
here as P_1, P_2, and P_3.
So we're going to
compute this area,
and we're going to do it
using the cross product, which
we learned about in lecture.
So why don't you take some
time to work this out,
pause the video, and we'll
check back in a minute
and see how I did it.
Hello and welcome back.
So the first thing that I
like to do with a problem
like this is I like to draw a
picture so I can kind of think
about what's going on.
So we have this triangle
sitting out in space.
And we know that we want to
take a cross product in order
to compute its area, but
we need to be careful.
Cross product, it
doesn't make sense
to take cross product of points.
What makes sense is to take
cross product of vectors.
So the first thing
that we need to do
is build some vectors that
describe this triangle.
And the vectors that we need
to build are P_1P_2 and P_1P_3.
Since we're going to use these
in a minute, let's go ahead
and compute them now.
So P_1P_2 is just the
difference of P_2 minus P_1.
So we get a 0
minus a negative 1.
So we get 1, 2, and 1.
Let me just check my notes to
make sure I did that right.
Good.
And P_1P_3.
We get again 0
minus a negative 1.
So 1, we get minus
1, and then we get 1.
Let me again check my notes.
Very good.
OK.
So now that we
have these vectors,
we need to remember
that if we take
the absolute value of P_1P_2
cross product with P_1P_3,
this will be equal to the
area of the parallelogram they
enclose.
So let's get started by
computing this cross product.
So P_1P_2 cross P_2P_3.
So, remember, to
compute a cross product,
we take the determinant of a
matrix where we put in our unit
normal vectors i, j, and k.
And then we enter in, the
remaining entries of the matrix
are just the entries
of our vectors.
So we do [1, 2, 1].
And [1, -1, 1].
OK.
And so we can compute this.
And we get-- so the i component,
we get 2 minus a negative 1.
So we get 3.
Now the j component.
If we look at the cofactor
matrix, it's just [1, 1; 1, 1],
and that has determinant 0.
So our middle
component is just 0.
And finally the k component.
We get minus 1, minus another 2.
So altogether, we get minus 3.
So what that tells us
now is that this quantity
here, the magnitude
of the cross product,
is just 3 times the
square root of 2,
just looking at the length
of this vector here.
So we're almost done, but
let's go back and look
at what we had to start with.
We were interested in
the triangle over here
which was enclosed
by the vectors P_1P_2
and the vectors P_1P_3.
And what we just
computed is actually
the area of this parallelogram,
which as you can see
is twice the area
of the triangle
that we're actually
interested in.
So going back over here, we see
that the area of our triangle
is equal to 3 root
2, and we just
need to divide by 2
to get the triangle.
OK?
And I'll leave it at that.